they really sad time for me but what are
you gonna do that's life
you know they were my brother was steve
was scared of her
really yeah encounters in the past cuz
she because she it's because I you know
you know Pauly Shore and the shores they
specifically have this obsession with
Asians yeah yeah yeah this really mix
each state came from mitzi though she
this obsession with Asian or the Thai
workers yeah so she would go steam
coming here you want to work here you
shouldn't get in I'm here what do you
want to do manage and my brother's know
you know my what not telling you right
yeah she would always offer my brother a
job she's trying to collect yeah and
then one day collect Asians yeah yeah
one day Polly goes did come over to my
house for Thanksgiving my mom's here so
I dragged my brother Steve there right
and we do the only agents yeah we're
seeing at this table you know I think
you know there's other comics there and
we're eating turkey and I'm sitting next
to Missy right and my brother and I are
eating and then we hear this like
something clacking the table like that
right yeah and I look over and Mitzi has
her one foot on the table and she grew
her [ __ ] toenails so long that she'd
clack I guess this table right yeah and
like my brother and I just couldn't eat
after that and it's like she put on the
table and everyone was sitting there
yeah like that right and I you can't go
to Mitzi and go hey can you stop that
that's [ __ ] weird I can't eat you know
this shows how much of a boss you know
you just have yeah she just does what
she wants the Queen she just did that
and I was just sitting there going okay
I'm done can't eat this turkey eat this
turkey there's a witch's you don't say
call her a witch man
Guil don't call her which bro all right
guys
shout out to Alfred is but she did have
that look though she would wear um 40
scarves are on her like body and she and
totally and she without this long hair
that you know over her face and she kind
of Han Qi and with all those scarves and
their hair like kind of a hair and her
dementia a little bit it was pretty
scary and sad and after a while I
stopped saying hello because she just
didn't know who I was anymore it's like
when I saw said hi to Paul Mooney a
couple of months ago and I go hey Paul
and he goes who you and he forgot me
because he he too is going through some
sort of dementia yeah so it's sad you
know when people get to that age and
that happens you know but um on other
news
[Music]